a lot of banks will really deny this but
Banks actually have back doors into your
system just think about it for a moment
you log in to your bank account you know
through such and such.com and you have
to answer all of these ridiculous
questions and get a two-factor SMS
message sent to you so you can enter in
the code but people really don't realize
is that their Banks also have backdoor
access to where applications like your
Turbo Tax and your money management
software all of that how do you think
that connects to your Banks would these
backdoor connections into Banks things
continue to be an inherently insecure
millions of people have their
information stolen sold and used against
them